we all know the feeling of trying to get through
the work we have to do, to get to the work we
want to do, and that's where Watson Orchestrate
comes in. Watson Orchestrate helps you get more
done by letting you create your very own digital
employees, or digeys. Digeys are extensions of you
that take on different jobs in the background,
while you handle the important stuff. Work that
used to take hours, now takes minutes, simply
assign your digeys the tasks you want them to
tackle, like sending emails, scheduling meetings,
and expediting requests, and they'll do the rest,
and they work seamlessly across the apps and
tools you already use like slack, linkedin,
salesforce, and more. Plus the more you work
together the smarter your digey becomes and the
more personalized your experience gets. Best
of all digeys give you the freedom to focus
on the work that truly matters
to you and your business.
It's time to leave the busy work
behind welcome to Watson Orchestrate.